is the culture median Sports Committee
of the House of Commons sent a letter to
tick tock saying while we recognize Tick
Tock is not the creator of the content
published by Mr brand and his content
may be within the community guidelines
set up by the platforms we are concerned
that he may be able to profit from his
content on the platform's holy what dude
confirmed conspiracy against Russell
brick I'm just really excited for this
we have a very quick confirmation of a
government
conspiracy against Russell Brand here's
the rumble tweet because Rumble is
awesome they they of course released
this with a statement saying today we
received an extremely disturbing letter
from a committee chair in the UK
Parliament while Rumble obviously
deplores sexual assault rape in all
serious crimes and believes that both
alleged victims and the accused are
entitled to full and serious
investigation it is vital to note that
the recent allegations against Russell
Brand have nothing to do with content on
rumble's platform